Thank You Hana thank you all so much for
coming it's my absolute delight to be
here with these because today I'll
introduce them in a moment but first
just to set the scene because we're
talking today about women and power and
I'm sure many of you will not need a
reason as to why we need a debate on
that subject but we're having it now and
the reason we're having it at this
particular moment in history is that as
many of you know last year the New York
Times ran a story that began by talking
about how Ashley Judd went to have
breakfast with the Hollywood producer
named Harvey Weinstein and so began
what's now become known as the me2
movement powerful men in the media the
arts business and film have been toppled
and humbled and women in the media and
organizations like the BBC have been
launching vocal campaigns about pay
equality what has actually changed we're
going to be asking that question in
three parts if you like first of all
we're going to be looking at the present
and what the meaty movement means right
now and how its interpreted by my
panelists here on the stage we're going
to go back in history and when I say
back in history I mean back way back
we're talking the millennia of history
of misogyny and silencing women and then
in the third part of our conversation
we're going to be looking at the
challenges that persist for women and
how we can envision a different future
so all light topics should be quite easy
to tackle in an era huh let me introduce
our speakers so when they said we're
going way back it can only be because we
have with us very beard professor of
classics at Newnham College Cambridge
and classic editor of the tls her books
includes the best-selling SPQR a history
of aints of ancient Rome and the recent
number one bestseller women empower a
manifesto which has been described in
glowing terms as a modern feminist
classic no
and she has as I'm sure you will know as
well presented several television
documentaries about the ancient world
and she was a presenter on the recent
landmark BBC series civilizations so
thank you for joining us Mary
[Applause]
[Music]
on my far left we have Miriam Gonzales
Miriam is co-chair of the law firm - at
LLP the international trade and
government regulation practice where she
advises on brexit and EU trade law
policy so she obviously had lots of time
to take out her agenda to be with us
this evening
I know her best as the founder and chair
of inspiring girls which is an
incredible charity that's dedicated to
raising the aspirations of young girls
around the world by connecting them with
female role models and she's also a
woman that I always enjoy saying who has
a husband and her husband weakened
defined by her career tonight and that's
former Deputy Prime Minister Nick Clegg
so thank you very much for joining us
[Applause]
[Music]
last but by no means least we have the
author commentator and activist Lorie
penny Laurie is one of the most
productive women in the media and I say
that from a position of informed
Authority
she's a contributing editor to the New
Statesman and she's also written for The
Guardian Time magazine BuzzFeed the New
York Times and vice she's written five
books seven but in the time the most of
us have returned one and bitch Doctrine
essays for dissenting adults was
published last year but the second
second edition has just come out and I'm
reading it and I highly recommend it
so please welcome Laurie pin
[Applause]
so I mentioned the New York Times story
about Ashley Judd and the Harvey
Weinstein and the events that followed I
want to start by asking each of my
panelists what went through your mind
when you first heard those revelations
last year very conflicting things truly
I mean certainly wasn't surprised you
know he didn't say oh my goodness me I
couldn't believe that I could i but then
you thought okay you know you do the
story about you know what Hollywood
stands for and the sexist structures of
Hollywood and you think oh we knew that
already didn't we assume that then you
thought I mean I felt guilt really
because I think you then searched I did
know that already if I didn't think I
knew that already didn't I ever think to
say you know what's going on there no I
just I'd shut up lucky for you so um no
surprise slight self-satisfaction about
knowledge followed by an uncomfortable
sense but maybe I ought to have spoken
up okay thanks Mary Laurie
well first I just wanted to say is a
huge huge honor to be here with all of
you guys in drinking kudos for having me
but I think when I first heard the
Harvey Weinstein story I thought whoo
come on like I mean I like I don't I
don't know who producers are I think I'm
not film journalists and then I am and
then I thought oh here we go again
because like there is this idea that
this is the first powerful man who has
been you know publicly brought down in
some way or people have tried to bring
him down by um by exposing you know we
have to say allegedly past past crimes
but this has been a running theme of you
know the work I've done in activism in
within feminism on the Left you know
again and again and again you know men
are accused of things
then there is a backlash and the women
involved the silence then it tears apart
social movements and I didn't know and I
think none of us knew that this would be
the watershed moment and it's very
interesting that this is this is how
it's happened and I I'd love to hear
people's theories as to why thanks sorry
Miriam but many many emotions really I
think I first of all disgust know is
when when the story comes happened you
think you know of course you're not
surprised at the same but 70 women in
relation to him really and there was
something in me thinking this absolutely
disgusting and then if I'm honest there
was a point that I felt a little bit of
an exclusion that's that though I have
always had it in my mind that some of
these skips going on I have always seen
at a personal level myself if you had
asked me personally I think that I have
always defined myself much more of a
mean either woman than me to woman and
you know at some point is like am i part
of this her or not and then the next
step for me was confusion and surprise
because talking about it I have come to
realize that I have a little box in my
brains and were there where I have
hidden things that have happened at some
points since that I know it may never on
that side always on the minitor side but
since I don't know it me that's that I
locked in there yes so that I don't have
to think about it and I know it's all
not only it's fantastic that women are
talking about it but it's all very
healthy that we all think about it
because we hide it and why did you hide
those bury those experiences or those
thoughts when you had we normalize it is
something that I go on in these pairing
girls campaign I think that we
normalized sexism and part of that
normalization of sexism is as you know
we get women of my generation personally
I have just been 50 so you know quite a
few years
I think that since that upset us in
order to deal with it we just we make it
a small we lock it better
everywhere we go on this is absolutely
fine it is not fine because it has a
massive effect on the next generation
lorry this goes back to your point about
the fact that there is nothing new in
this but it what's new is that it's it's
stuck it's a moment of traction and I
want to ask you as someone who's been an
activist on the Left all your adult life
and probably before well before that
what what is the difference that you
perceive in the narrative now and also
can you address this question of whether
this is this is about it started about
women in Hollywood this is an ongoing
debate about whether this is a movement
for privileged women is it really
helping with grassroots issues about
domestic violence in the home about
women and immigration detention it has
it become a broader part of the feminist
activist scene well I would hope so
I am very suspicious not that like
feminism has a problem the feminist
movement as a whole has a problem with
privilege a problem with race and a
problem Okin as most political movements
do right and those are things that I
have found feminist activists eventually
quite good at cleaning house on you know
quite good at your at collecting people
and saying and I am I am very suspicious
when when I hear powerful white men come
to me and say well isn't this a bit
privileged you know isn't this a bit
isn't feminism a bit too privileged
right now I'm like no I'm not hearing
that from you know there's there are
only certain people I won't you know I
will tolerate that from there is a use I
think in this coming from
not just from privileged women but from
Hollywood because these are people who
we've we've all seen I mean even if we
don't know who producers are like if
we've all seen on our screens in stories
we've seen them as women who have been
given other people's lines to say women
who have often literally been cast as
victim
in you look at Rose McGowan who we spoke
to a front row the other day and she's
somebody who has literally been cast as
somebody who is deserving of sexual
violence in film after film and then to
have these people turn around and say it
happened to us well you start thinking
well if it happened to them it can
happen to anyone
maybe this deal maybe even at the top of
the pile of privilege maybe it was maybe
it's not a good deal it deal in the
first place you know the deals you meant
to make with patriarchy and I think
there has been and it has served as a
point of opening to discuss other issues
within feminism to discuss class to
discuss race and all of the problematic
things that have come up I have found
people open to discussing them but I
mean maybe that's me being Pollyanna but
it's not often what I'm accused of so
very once I I'd like to think that when
Laurie said this was a watershed moment
that she was right you know and I I hope
that me two moves from being hashtag me
to to being challenged because hashtags
are easy and change is hotter so if I
was going to predict count of 20 years
hence and one version of that prediction
ago this was the moment when suddenly
you know eyes opened and we thought no
you know stop it just stop guys no the
other poll should me thinks that yes and
it really goes back to what I said I
suppose about being on the surprised
about the stories that came out was that
if what you think is that this is about
you know ultimately what's causing this
it's not nasty men some of them aren't
some of them may not be what's causing
this is the structures of gender power
in Hollywood
elsewhere then the logic for me is you
only are going to solve the problem if
you really get to grips with the
structures of power so that you know how
many some like three percent of
Hollywood directors are female
etc etc so I I am a torn between
thinking that actually vocalizing can
sometimes really change things and on
the other hand more gloomily thinking
that this is a kind of there's a certain
feel good at the phenomenon here but
it's still going to be the guys in power
they're still going to be the ones you
call the shots they're not necessary in
Hollywood but in you know you can name
any institution and that that is if you
really want to stop the harvey's of this
world that's what you've got to change
and a hashtag doesn't do that well we're
going to talk more about structural
questions and the future of the
patriarchy of misogyny but I want to ask
you about the generational divide that
seems to have opened up just coming back
to the confines of the mean to move
because it's undeniably there who can
forget Germaine Greer comments listen
there have been a number of women of
dare I say it your generation thank you
thank you
most III in a bit you know that I and I
experienced it myself this point of heat
where women say what we've all had our
bump in just get on with it yeah well I
have had my bump its time worth um I
think I'm not certain that that's what
is that but that's the root of the
generational divide and what I think
that what it's very easy to forget that
I I was kind of you know I was being my
radical Laurie you know in the late
sixties and through the seventies and
our campaigns were just so utterly
different then I mean we did you know we
did think
that the age of consent was something
that we wanted to abolish no because we
actually sat there and said look you
know Here I am and you adults are
stopping me have a sex life you know and
we didn't the the idea of exploitation
of kids as now seems absolutely natural
for us to think about that did not cross
our minds and the idea that that somehow
what you were fighting was the rules
that stopped you sleeping with who you
wanted to leaving aside the power
dimensions you thought you thought that
what you were what you were doing was
batting at the old God and that the we
to demolish the old God meant you know
I'm gonna fuck who I want to and and
that was that was what I know I you know
now of course I you know I can see all
the things that in saying that we didn't
see you know in hindsight but I still
think a lot of us it's not about I mean
I think people say I'd never mind having
my bum pinched by the photocopier I
think I'm talkin Tosh but I think people
in my generation have done a vault first
or being asked to do evolve us I think
rightly probably so are you saying that
they're still stuck on this idea of kind
of personal agency if you can be allowed
to choose who you sleep with
and therefore if you decide to go to
audition wearing your underwear I don't
you know that is where I'm not endorsing
that that respect does not be clear I
think that I don't actually think that
we thought that through you know I think
we didn't think it's true but I think
that deep ingrained in me is that the
conservative right patriarchy actually
wants to stop me sleeping with who I
want you and and I'm sure that goes for
Jemaine you know who says
three mean stupid things really
extremely to do quick things but
sometimes you know I can't you know the
female unit was a changing kind of book
for me and I can't throw Tremayne over
entirely I can't
and I think buried in all that complete
crass stupidity you know in order to get
on the front page of every sorting
newspaper there are some actual grains
of intelligent torment I won't tell you
what they are now because it will drive
Laurie mad but I can feel I can feel the
very desperate but I think it is it
there is the generational thing is that
we feel that we the terrain of battle
has changed Laurie
all right so
hey now know what I'm gonna say
I wonder if this door so it was so
watching you process Mary thing no
cottony between I want to challenge you
on the ducati between you know the fight
against sexual oppression and the fight
against sexual repression which is very
much you know what German grey was about
with the Female Eunuch and it was a
hugely it was a I was kind of a if
people like I have a very specific
history with feminist activism and that
like I was I actually was like a pink
haired feminist before it was cool in a
weird way like back in the 90s when
nobody was a feminist like you know and
we didn't have the Internet in the same
way so oh I only knew one of the
feminists and I was told that feminism
was over and then I discovered Germaine
Greer and it was like you know I was
really into it in the way that you're
into things when you're fourteen you
know and you never quite in the same way
again but I think the sexual liberation
is exactly what movements like me to are
about and the idea that's being handed
down to us not by an older generation of
feminists but you know there are certain
people who've been kind of do Julie
Hartley brewer who have been sort of
like I didn't say anything but who have
been recruited to say all these young
people they're so prudish you know they
don't you know no wonder nobody's
shagging anymore but no that's
absolutely what it's about sexually are
they still yes I hope so I was warned
that we would need to stay focused but I
didn't say the go this summer yeah like
you cannot have sexual liberation
without addressing sexual violence and
you cannot talk honestly about consent
without talking about sexual liberation
and I think this idea that it's a fight
between people who are empty sex and
throw sex is just not on the idea that
if you if you are pro sexual liberation
is not what Mary is saying I know like
if you're a pro sexual liberation then
you somehow have to just like be pro
being grabbed whenever you want to
that's not liberation for me that is
repression
it's exploitation and oppression but
with the the generation gap thing I
think there is there is a divide in some
ways between what is often known as you
know the second wave generation of
feminists and you know and the new guard
and I think in some ways we don't pay
enough we don't give enough respect to
people to struggles that have gone on
before I think that's true but also I
think there is a sense especially among
women who have not like you know spent
their whole lives immersed in this sort
of activism the you know maybe young
people they're just asking for too much
you know God you know can't they put up
with anything you know we we have to be
strong enough to deal with all this so
why aren't they and the answer is of
course like why should we be why should
anyone be like I'm totally strong enough
to deal with someone grabbing me I just
don't I can't be bothered I can't be
bothered to negotiate all of that
bullshit but I answer later feels to do
it sounds like you're quite forgiving of
Germaine Greer in the context of her
what she's contributed to feminism into
your feminism I'm not angry I'm
disappointed
probably more Casa Ivanovic Miriam is
this endless push now to try to see all
the my new to differences between every
single thing that each one of us is
saying whether it is different
backgrounds whether it is different
generations I actually don't see we
don't see that movement towards the
sexual liberation and what is happening
I was Amy to us two different things I
think that they are completely
complimentary I want to sleep with
whoever I want and by the way I don't
want to have to sleep with my employer
simply because he happens to be my
employer now we can get into the kind of
grey zones that we make ways and wait
forever but clearly a lot of this is not
about the crazy grey zones and it is
very clear that many of those behaviors
are indeed abusive for me the same goes
for that previous debate as to whether
this is privileged women or not
privileged women I mean some of those
privileged women they are really taking
action
and some of them have actually put money
for the legal cases is fantastic that
now we are going from the voice and the
noise and I always say and I hope that
we can get into that later and I think
it comes through in in your book very
clearly that the main one of the main
perhaps to make it fairer instruments of
power is your voice and it's the noise
that you can make with it they are
actually translating it into real action
including legal action I'm perfectly
happy to see a lot of privileged women
from Hollywood or whatever just joining
their forces to what everybody is doing
I actually want to see more privileged
men as well joining in and I think that
something that has happened which it was
an unlimited I think that the main thing
that has been a social sense things that
were acceptable have stopped being
acceptable people are thinking about
things that most of us didn't even think
about beforehand I think I will change
in terms it will translate into the
structures of power you can see it over
here my country we had today this
morning a government 61% women that
would not have happen if if everybody
was not talking about women our and how
come in and meet human movement I know
it wasn't only me to it I started with
the move the merits of of women there is
somebody a very privileged man that we
have we have to thank for for all this
and in my view is president
[Laughter]
can I just like to bring a slap on topic
like can I come back to you because we
are going to trump is it's the perfect
moment to leave person flee Italy Oh
Laurie playing right we will come back
after you Laurie and we will
unfortunately I expect come back to
trump but first we're going to take a
little meander through the millennium
and Mary to ask you about your book
women in power which I have to say I
found profound because it revealed to me
certain tropes and prejudices that I
lived with whose roots I had no idea of
and to realize that so many things that
seem part of kind of contemporary
trolling are thousands of years old it
was really fascinating tell us about the
book how it came about and what the main
argument is well there's lots of you can
tell lots of different stories about how
you wrote a book
and you know the truth is that the two
main chapters of the book for two
lectures that I did for the London
Review of Books at the British Museum
and you know in the way that anybody who
has been asked to give a lecture and is
a procrastinator knows I didn't know
what to say you know I said yeah I'll do
a lecture for you and they were pressing
me and then the editor rings up and says
look no you tell it's really urgent
because she rang she didn't email I just
don't know what to say so she said it
for the first one and she did the same
for the second one talk about the voice
of women talk about women's voices and
actually when you get a really good
editor what they do is they tell you the
subject that you didn't realize you
wanted to talk about right
once she said that you know I like a
really really good undergraduate student
I thought right I'm going to write an
essay on women's voice and I was that
smile freed me up and I saw I mean they
kind of pain Lee dropped that I've been
talking you know I don't know which wave
feminism it is but I've been talking
feminism for most of my life and I've
been doing classic
and I'd make some attempts to put those
two things together but actually when I
got that you know that new essay topic I
thought right actually these two bits of
my life they they're the same you know
they're the same they're not different
and so what I found myself doing in in
both the the chapters and the original
lectures that um adopted the book was
thinking about the really really long
history of the way that women are shut
up and the way that women's power is
removed from them and I'll just give you
two very quick examples the first
example is goes right back to the
beginning of Western literature and it
is Homer's Odyssey in eighth century BC
we're right at the Wellsprings of what
we might call Western culture and in the
first book of Homer's Odyssey the mother
of this Reedy teenager Telemachus is
shot by her son penelope comes
downstairs she's in the palace of it
secure she's waiting for Odysseus her
husband to get back home from the Trojan
War she hears a boring old bard singing
about what a terrible time the great
heroes are having and she says please
can you play a nicer tune perfectly
reasonable request and Telemachus says
shut up mother speech his man's business
go back upstairs and she does
and I'd read that you know I first read
The Odyssey when I was about 16 I lied
read that but then you know 40 40 years
and I've never spotted it you know I'd
read it but I'd never seen it is about
silencing women and suddenly you think
right okay let me think about my own
experience of being silent son of people
look at me now and can't imagine I never
silence but I tell you I am right I was
at meeting today which I was hardly sort
of
because there is something about public
speech which is quite different from
what we're doing here much public speech
is still coded as male men in suits you
know when you you know you still feel
about 15 when you try to kind of make
the point and you really analyze the
voice the sound of women's voices and
how they've been defined as kind of
sweetly did my pitch screeches you know
look what you did you know she the one
thing she did to make herself picked
templates of power was she went and took
voice lessons so she spoke deeply and
you only have to look at early Thatcher
videos and late Thatcher videos and she
sounds different I'm not any better but
you know credit where it's G I just want
to introduce an image at the stage which
we have because speaking of politicians
who've been attacked because of the
sound of their voice this if anyone
isn't any doubt about how vicious in
contemporary misogynist are of ancient
he richer is Donald Trump with the head
of Hillary Clinton I was very very
conscious tipped off by a friend of mine
in the States who said look at the
imagery with which Trenton was attacked
by the Trump supporters and she said it
goes back to the old myth of Perseus the
Greek hero who decapitates the vicious
snake he locked mobster female Medusa
who by her very look will turn anyone to
stone I went I put Medusa
Perseus Trump Clinton into Google Images
[Laughter]
hundreds of images of the decapitation
of Clinton by our Perseus type hero and
what I thought was very striking about
was that you know if you go into the
darker recesses of the web you can find
pretty nasty images you know of
attacking Obama this was not this was
kind of domestic you could get this on
t-shirts or mouse mats or mugs on tote
bags you know you could feel the
domestic space of your house with the
image of decapitation and I just thought
and you are batting an eyelid at this an
interestingly when Kathy Griffin did her
sketch on American television in which I
feel extremely nasty and enticed 'less
in which she held off the decapitated
head of Cutrone
she was sacked you know or enjoying this
on their coffee mug why is that and
again it fits into this kind of the idea
and it in some ways it's deeply
depressing in other ways it's kind of it
really helps to kind of see but these
tropes the tropes by which we write off
women the way we talk about them the way
we we remove their power from they're
not no they're not things that were even
invented in the last century they are
things which have been central to
Western culture as far back as we can
see it don't mean by that that I think
they are natural but I mean they're very
very deeply ingrained culturally learned
tropes which silence women and for good
measure cut their heads off does it say
something that the kind of founding
civilization of Western culture the
Roman Empire was founded on this myth of
the mass rape of women yeah
interestingly I think the Romans Roman
writers were much more reflective about
what the idea of the rape of the Sabine
meant about their culture then we often
are
about our own rape narratives and then
the Romans were brutal crew and they
founded that polity on images of
violence against women but they did at
least recognize they did it we tend not
even to notice it I mean I mean I assume
if you have that on your coffee mug
you're not really noticing what it is
Orissa that's hope or you are and that's
is this insight useful to see a kind of
consistency or did you find that our
contemporary narrative is a direct
descendant of this very moon Greek
mythology and literature I mean we're
not simply the descendants thank heavens
of Greece and Rome you know you know you
know cults has got a bit more diverse
and you know there are other influences
we're not kind of poor little pawns of
the Greeks and Romans but I think you
can trace the way that those images have
been presented to us and naturalized for
us I think that it's somehow it's about
the way in a way this comes back to the
kind of ode in a bottom pinched by the
photocopier the way we have learned to
think of this as a kind of natural state
of affairs and I'm afraid you know I'm
going to confess that and I'm certainly
implicated in that and I think all of us
on the one time it really struck me was
the first time I got on a plane and the
announcement came from the pilot which
said we're going to be flying at 30,000
feet or whatever it was and the pilots
voice was female and I remember for that
speed second I thought why is the cabin
attendant during this announcement
another Oh blimey the pilots a woman you
know having spread lunch in my life
wanting and encouraging women to go into
male occupations there's still that you
know but that long learnt assumption
that the guy flying the plane the guy it
reminded me of when I first went since a
TV broadcasting where to be very
friendly advice I was given by a helpful
male boss was you might want to try
lowering the pitch of your voice we find
that view is preferred but Miriam do you
recognize the narratives that Mary's
describing in the book I do and that is
a lot of the core of what we are trying
to fight against with with inspiring
girls precisely to try to tackle that at
a very early age and incidentally what
we find in the campaign we are in 78
today because we have opened in Colombia
as well but no matter the country no
matter the background no matter whether
it is a school that is doing well or not
what we find everywhere is that around
the age of 1213 there is an issue of
lack of self-confidence it is at that
age that girls I started thinking our
perhaps this job is not for me or
perhaps the subjects is not relief for
girls this is port menapii and it's like
you know it trickles down there in their
mind and I'm absolutely convinced that
that is what later on leads to women
thinking that your boss assuming that he
gonna sleep with you is normal as some
have said or that for example you don't
need to ask for a higher salary because
know you're a woman or what it is is
something that installs itself there in
the back of your mind if we were able to
kill it you know by the route early on
we would all be in a in a much better
position i I think I it's not that I
disagree but I see the slightly
differently because I think there has
been a change definitely in the last few
years in the sense that we don't think
that it is natural or okay but some of
these things happen to women I think
that's
it has moved the the arrow has moved a
little bit there and that we actually
know it is not ok but we think because
he's not too bad is not as bad as it was
whenever you couldn't vote or whenever
didn't even have equal pay or whatever
it's kind of okay let's live with it and
I think that is that bit that we need to
fight against now it is not ok it is not
good enough to say well in our country
we have so many right we don't have it
on an equal basis women and that's what
I want
I just want equal rights you know it's
not so difficult
Laurie does it help the contemporary
struggle to know this history does it
play a pipe a practical role to be able
to trace certain roots say to Greek
mythology I think it adds so alright one
of the things that has happened in the
past year especially the past six months
and and Miriam is right when she says
you know Trump has done a great deal
paradoxically to bring the women's
movement in some ways together because
it shows it gives its evidence right
the noise was coming from inside the
house you were not crazy this is
actually happening we actually have you
know the troll in chief pussy grabber in
chief there are people who will vote for
that guy and you know and and all these
things that you know some of us have
been saying for a long time yeah I hate
to have been right all along
actually that's not what I'm kind of
doing this work before but an intern but
in terms of talking about the history of
women being silenced and the mythology
of it it lends it lends you know that
that vital intellectual credibility to
what people are experiencing now in
terms of being silenced yet again
particularly around you know around
issues of sexual violence domestic
violence workplace harassment you know
hostile work environments it's um so
look we we talked briefly about social
media earlier and we talked about know
the limits or or otherwise of hashtag
to vision but look I know that I'm never
sure that both Mary and I and I'm sure
you guys as well
have experienced a great deal of
harassment and silencing when we tried
to do our jobs and for me a lot of my
job does involve writing on the internet
because like this is doing events like
this is good because then I get out of
the house and I talk to actual people
but yeah most of most of this so I'm
very excited to be with other humans
it's like live action Twitter raising
which I really remember Laurie and you
wrote that you wish you'd been a
restaurant critic restaurant critics get
free meals you get death threats
actually I kind of like travel
journalist is right up there you know
travel but but yeah I guess it's part of
what you do that you are regularly faced
with horrific yes absolutely and it
shouldn't be and it is not just from
anonymous trolls on the internet that's
a cop-out it's from you know I have been
harassed front by journalists from you
know all kinds of well-known
publications and I've had I went through
I wrote a big piece about it lately and
I found you know male journalists I
thought I admired writing like just
disgusting patronizing stuff about me
when I was 23 years old you know this
guy was you know so much older and just
like wrote a whole column about like how
how rubbish I was like the attacks the
attacks have been relentless and the
cylla and the attempts to silence and
you know is lucky and and the thing is
why are they doing this because because
there's a threat when women are actually
allowed to speak and when they are
allowed to speak to each other look what
happens but it's under men is it only
minute of out of curiosity because in my
case some of the biggest sexist comments
and attacks have come from women some of
them yeah and I I think that we are
moving into a situation where this is
much more about men and women who share
one model of society and men are women
who share a different model that this is
just not so much different genders when
every other
[Applause]
Laurie it's just look I think
internalized patriarchy is a thing right
and I'm saying no this is not what
you're saying but I'm sick of somebody
pointing and saying look just because
one woman is also being it to get one no
no I know that I don't know that's not
what you're saying but I
I will fight sexism wherever it appears
some women are extremely sexist that
doesn't mean that the problem isn't
gender and sexism and that doesn't mean
that those women do not eventually
benefit you know I don't I take the
purview I don't need necessary nice if
those women were on board now but I will
still continue to fight for their rights
and I hope other people will tell you
it's better leave that angle if I make
it there are lots of men who don't agree
with those fears well they'll make sure
they don't know about the liberation of
the meat you of making this a big issue
to discuss a society and I bet perfectly
by that we have you know I agree
completely on that we have centers and
centuries that we need to change name
but it is wonderful to see how many have
joining
eventually honest that is true that it's
wonderful but I think that one of the
things that taking the long view helps
you with is to see that it's not just
about either kind of practical issues
like like I used to think it was you
know workplace no stress or whatever and
it's not actually just about whether
you're kind of on board or not but I
think that looking back to antiquity
what really sensitized me to that's
right meet you two with one own right
but it sensitized me to you was the was
the use of language
one thing that I've been really struck
by is that how unreflective we are about
the language that we use about about a
neutral language about women and men and
the one thing I would really really like
to change
I might see this before I fall off my
perch is I'd like if you think that the
word ambitious a new say of a man he's
ambitious
that's roasting penetrating going places
you know really good ambitious young man
right woman's ambition that is not a
compliment and somehow I think it's not
just the case of consciously thinking
the right thing you know I'm very
pleased when men come on board but I
think that this goes our hell of a lot
deeper into the structures that we don't
even examine look look at the word deep
you know you've got a deep voice and
you're really profound and you're a
bloke you know and I know there is so
much more we could keep discussing on
this but I do want to move it forward
cuz we're running out of time and and
Mary I won't have really pin you down
because one of the things I found most
fascinating about women of power and it
relates this question of structure was
your assertion that we should change the
way we think about power that we think
of power as an attribute or a noun
something you have that perhaps we
should think about it as a verb to power
that if women are to be powerful in ways
they were not allowed to be powerful and
in the past that we would need to
reframe our thinking around how can you
explain what you mean by the simple
logic which is to say if through all the
reasons as I go through I think in the
book if women don't fit the structures
of power as they're currently defined
one thing you might do is change the
women what so that they fit maybe we
should think of it differently from the
other end and say let's change the power
not the girls now that's quite easy to
say you know it's harder to deliver on
with a kind of 10-point action plan for
how we're going to change the structure
of power in this you know in the world
but I mean I think you know
don't have to give us ten points because
one or two um I'm an academic and I
always think they're just thinking
things through is always important but
I'm I'm very conscious just in my own
university world of the way actually
ideas or the certain sense of male
leadership has developed you know so I
get invited to course is frequently
about how to be a leader and I've I now
write back when I get these invitations
on my email saying I will go to one of
those when I can also go on a course
about how to be a follower because
leaders imply followers and actually
isn't that the dichotomy that we need to
be breaking done I think it's this is
not about when just think of the word to
wield yeah that's what we use with but
what you do with power you wield it
right what else do you wield a sword and
a phallus right now so you know there's
a kind of celebrity about it there's
thrusting perishers let's just say we
want to get some things done actually
and we want to get some things done
together and um maybe collaboration and
taking different worlds that's what I
did mention in the book you know when I
was trying to think of some example it
was black lives matter was then it still
seems to me largely true
it was example of a movement in which
the protagonists were both super
effective in changing the political
landscape and did not become celebrities
now of course it's possible to say they
didn't become celebrities because they
were three black women right and so they
remained anonymous but you can turn that
and you can say look actually one of the
most powerful changes on the scene of
contemporary u.s. poll
Jaques has been a movement in which most
people could not name the leaders and
you see that not as a failure to become
symbols of power but as a wave Li a
reinvention of power is something that
doesn't involve celebrity or attention
importance
I'm going to try to see it that way all
right I'm going to try to see it not as
these women that if it had been three
white men doing this would have been all
over every television screen and but
actually saying it is possible to make
changes without that model of thrusting
maleness white male
Laurie just to play devil's advocate to
what Mary is saying is that not giving
up isn't that saying we you know as
women we can't we can't do this so we
have to reimagine why can't women
inhabit the power that already exists
and is it okay to make to abandon their
well the power that already exists was
built by men for men and you know as
long as that's the only model we have of
power women are always going to lose
whether or not they're inside or outside
that power it's pretty I don't know it's
pretty simple I'm not very attached to
the current way we conceptualize either
politics or economics you know I think
we have to problematize those
hierarchies as well it's yeah we think
about power I think is something women
have or as opposed to have individually
and this is where I um I it's really
hard to talk about problems with in
contemporary feminism without having
people reframe it as oh look it's girls
shouting at each other because actually
does it look a bunch of men said what
exactly what Germaine Greer said far
worse right and they've been saying it
for centuries but soon as Germaine Greer
says it's like Oh women fight each other
go on and it's not that the real enemy
is outside the feminist movement but
there is a certain limit to a feminism
which only is only concerned with
empowering individual women and if
there's one thing that I've I've had
solidified for me by the me2 movement
and personal experiences I've had with
that it's that we build power together
it's not it like asthma it is not just
about leaders it's about structures and
structures coming up from below and it
is about solidarity which is an
unfashionable word but solidarity being
the fact that you don't you don't even
have to like each other and that was a
great revelation to me you don't have to
like other women who you're hanging out
with in order to have their back you
know you have their back first and you
believe them until until you heard it
this is the yes
I think that in some ways there are some
really simple points here yep because
what I think most women want is actually
what they don't currently have which is
to be taken seriously they want you know
I don't expect people to agree with me
necessarily expect to have arguments I
could go on with Laurie disagreeing you
know the hours but I I what I feel I
don't have I mean he might say it looks
as if I've got this in spades I don't
think that my words are taken as
seriously as a male coeval I never have
been either and it's like look I I agree
but also like if I can't and obviously I
am not working within academia I like
I'm like somebody who writes on the
Internet I don't have to be inside those
structures but like I have been told
when I started coming up as journalists
what I needed to do to get men to take
me seriously and I have done none of
those things almost and and and I have
not been taken seriously and I have
examined this thoroughly and I've
realized I don't care I don't care if
men take me seriously i care they take
me seriously I do think that the
structures of power are changing I don't
think I has anything to do with a gender
debate I think I has to do with
technology frankly and the fact that now
we can connect with each other and
therefore that changes completely the
dynamic as to how you can affect change
if you want to see leadership in that
way I the problem I have with that
premise of you either change the power
or do you change the women is that it
assumes that there is such thing as the
women that we share something I have
real problems accepting that because I
think that we are all different you know
that normally that debate leads on to we
are better at negotiating
we tend to look for consensus we are
more patient we are more diplomatic now
I have been a negotiator in in the past
I'm probably not a very good example of
that be nice even I prefer people do
what I say rather than having to
negotiate I don't feel that anybody
would say that I am diplomatic and the
other thing that I have is that I'm
really impatient so yes perhaps all
these instructions of power need to
change by while they are changing I
really want women not only to get more
power but also to show it and to show it
to the girls and for me the biggest
change in the last few years that have
happened with women in power is that for
many years we were getting women in
power who were the very best women the
top of the cup you know they had a turn
with few exceptions of course but most
of them it was amazing when they made it
there because it was like going through
aging kana finally we are seen video /
women in power a pair quite a few the
government here
[Applause]
like we're talking about should we
change power or should we change women
like maybe we could change men like
thank you talk about what the trouble is
and the thing that nobody is like I
think maybe we're stepping around is
that there are some points at which
giving you know it's not the problem
isn't rape isn't only that women have
not enough power it's that men have too
much and we need to take some of that
away we do sorry like and that's
uncomfortable to hear it's uncomfortable
to hear no I think that's up to you
right and I think that you know we're
looking for a social and political
revolution and in the end revolutions
have losers as well as winners there is
no such thing as a revolution in which
everybody wins and so I'm afraid I'm
with you Laurie on this that that
actually this is in part about giving up
power and Oh taking it away from the
buggers
time for you to ask questions and I'm
going to take two or three at a time
just to try and keep things moving but I
will do my best there's so many hands
already I will do my best to come to all
of you say the first lady I saw is this
person here lady in the black up there
and keep your hands up gentlemen
right at the back there those are the my
first three yes
thank thank you very honored to be the
first one to ask a very question I'm
just starting reading your women and
power book I must tell you when I was
reading the this a story the first thing
that upset me was that no person a funny
and great epiphany yeah Penelope sorry I
was confused too to was supposed to
entertain and cater to all these lovers
that were potential lovers rather not so
much the fact that Taylor Marcus which
in my eyes who admires try to protect
her right so the the sort of taken for
granted hospitality that women are
supposed to provide it's very much the
the normal hero image of women that I
think we should fight more than a fact
that men try to protect us thank you
we're gonna come to after I've taken all
three may yes yes hi thank you for the
opportunity to ask the question I've I'm
a clinical psychologist I've spent the
last nine months almost exclusively
working with senior executives in the
city mostly all men because they're very
senior and behind closed off behind
closed doors I can say without breaching
any of any confidentiality that there is
a crisis of masculinity and men of my
generation and I like you Maria at 50
and so my question is this if we're
asking men to give up power and I think
a lot of them even the very privileged
and successful realize this paradigm
doesn't work for them in terms of
fulfillment happiness all of those
things that people start to look for in
midlife
then what are we going to fill that if
they if they let go
what are we filling it with because of
vacuum needs to be filled so have we
thought through what this new paradigm
is going to look like in sufficient
detail for both women and men for this
vacuum to be filled in a healthy way
thank you very much thank you that was
the gentleman there yeah hi I'd um I'd
like to pick under than something that
Laurie said at the very end which was
perhaps men need to change and the
question for the panel is how do you go
about doing that so for example Miriam
with your inspiring girls is it time to
bring boys into the fold as well thank
you very much great questions right Mary
its we haven't talked about Penelope's
free hospitalities that is that
something women are still is that still
a problem here Penelope is a much more
complicated character than I was letting
on because she is both forced to give
free hospitality to these loads of louts
that have occupied her palace while her
husband's away but she's also of course
really smart you know how as a girl you
learn the Odyssey but now that B's
really smart because she says she'll
choose her husband when she's finished a
piece of weaving that she does and every
night she on Reeves is so she never
finishes so I was I was told the story
of Penelope when I was a kid as a story
of female while eNOS that I should
actually emulate no humble woman who was
shut up by her teenage son and not only
I think in the structure of the Odyssey
he's not only just shut up as a compass
on the Odyssey is partly a story of this
son Telemachus becoming becoming a man
he growing up he moves from boy to man
and actually the first instance you see
of Telemachus his maturation is he tells
his mother to go upstairs
right and that is really what what in
the end struck me not just that he tells
us to shut up
but that Greek men learnt to be men by
shutting women up that was part of being
a man their identities where is it kind
of leads on to the the next question
about this question for crisis of
masculinity and and if we take power
away from men and we create a void we
fill it with well there's always a
crisis in masculinity then the
experience of masculinity is is a crisis
is of deep loneliness and and fear and
fear of other men and you know I've been
talking a lot to a lot of men over the
past you know year and through the me2
thing and and that's what I'm hearing
over and over again is that how should
how should we be better men how am I
supposed to be a man and what nobody is
asking is well how am I supposed to be a
person I think maybe the question is not
how you feel how you find fulfillment as
a man but what if your humanity was the
was the more important thing you know
you the standards of masculinity if you
are gonna subscribe you can't win that
masculinity game even if you do and be
like does anybody think that they Donald
from business psychologically healthy
person who's who doesn't you know you
know wake up in the night sweating and
you know tormented by nightmares and
does anybody think it's fun to inhabit
that body
I don't think so there even though you
look it is not the the concept of
masculinity that we have right now is
toxic and and should be junked not only
for the sake of women who have to cope
with it and you know we're always asked
now what will we offer men it's not
about what we have to offer men is about
how men can be fully human and live
within themselves and learn to care to
do that care work for themselves and I
think that starts by there's this
brilliant as this fantastic Gloria
Steinem line which is you know women
have to learn to be the men we wanted to
marry and learn how to husband
themselves and I think like that's
something that the feminist movement in
some ways has taught us by think
there is a corollary whereby you know
men need to learn how to kind of be
their own wives because varium a be
unfair to a senior executive men in the
city to kind of have Trump as the model
of I mean no one's gonna question that
masculinity isn't quite as if trouble
what is it do the I'm curious as to
whether the other senior lawyers you
work with her men whether you recognize
this crisis of masculinity well I
personally think that there is much more
change than what we give credit for here
in the type of discussions that we have
amongst us and I think that the I for
example I'm sure that I have much more
in common with pretty much every man who
is here in this room than with any
female voters of Trump or any female
writers of the Daily Mail I mean they
divide his society is very different now
and and of course part of this involves
had a big discussion as to somebody will
lose some of that power and at an
individual level that may feel painful
at some points it also involves having
some discussions about things that we
have left as taboos and one of the big
taboos is the Society of care we care
for children we care for elderly parents
we care for one another
somebody has to do that we sort of hide
it some of that is going to feel painful
and it may have some repercussions by
the way including on taxation that we
don't even want to touch so far so I I'm
perfectly aware of all that but I for
example have never had as many
conversations as to what you have to
feed babies then with the mailing
members of my team and they had
completely opened some of those young
men to their responsibilities personally
if I may answer in grateful inspiring
girls because something but we have
really noticed although it's not a
question they may need to change should
you include boys insider training you do
just what we have noticed there is that
when we bring boys on board on the kind
of you know we normally have one woman
and 28 girls or say if we get boys there
which was her initial instant most of
the questions come from boys
and is completely shocking when you see
it if you remove the boys they're all
the questions of course it becomes an
anoxic also something that I'm
completely shocked about all the time is
that we continue getting questions these
are twelve thirteen years old girls in
2018 you still get questions about can
you really do that job and have a family
is shocking really
but that's where probably enough for
once I got a practical suggestion it
goes but a lot early doesn't it and it
goes back to how we and we're all
implication this certainly I think I was
um in what we expect oh how we trained
little boys to be boys and you know and
there's a lot of discussion about it and
I remember vividly I think taking very
much the wrong path you know and making
sure that you know you know my daughter
had a train she didn't want and the son
had a Barbie dolls you know fine long
ago this ever did but when actually you
get any playground and you see time and
again boys being told not to cry to be
brave to man up and the way that we
treat those kids when they're five or
six you can see you know so but on the
twelve or thirteen you're reaping the
rewards of that with having inspiring
girls here in the UK we did a parallel
campaign with primary schools and we
brought panels of six people in a men
and women to six-year-old boys and girls
and we asked what kind of job do you
think that these people have and you
will be completely six years old that
they can hardly explain to you properly
the biological difference between men
and women men banker doctor boss
they say boss if this woman teacher
NORs young and pretty model and
facilities party organizers
Wow amazing
oK we've got time for one more round of
questions maybe two if we keep it short
so thank you okay I'm curious as to the
panel's view as to some of the reasons
why women haven't always been able to
organize I mean I sort of have a theory
which is around the fact that other
people from other disadvantaged
communities will often live together so
you know Jewish people fighting
anti-semitism and often live in Jewish
communities and LGBT people will often
live in those and they're the people
they're living with but women tend to
live separately with their male than
families and their children and I'm
wondering to what extent that has held
us back especially when you look at
what's been happening with gay marriage
in Ireland and how I feel sometimes that
that's leaping forward ahead of some of
the women's issues not that it shouldn't
but that it is and obviously with the
internet it's what we've already said
that that's changed things but I'm
curious as to the panel's view as to
whether they think that that is one of
the things that's held women back from
moving forward in the last thirty years
thank you very much to woman and
exposing their bodies sexually do you
think it's a good thing because they are
empowering their bodies is what they are
or do you think it's a bad thing because
most of them might be doing it to please
man thank you okay thank you thank you
and then there was hello first of all
congratulations to Miriam for being full
of common sense and weed and very
inspiring ideas and humor an emphasis on
and second of all I read recently that
one of the biggest challenges that we're
confronting is how not to trivialize
rape and how not to criminalize flirting
where do you stand on that one thank you
is that for Miriam specifically or for
anybody that wants one second okay thank
you very much all right and Laurie I'm
interested in your view on the question
of organizing whether it's whether the
fact that we don't have female
communities and we're dispersed and in
households with men and that's
absolutely part of it but look there are
if you look right back through through
history and myth and you know and and
the narratives that we've had you know
throughout you know the history of
Western culture is stories about women
as the only woman in the group or women
as each other's enemies and and do you
think there are in the workplace as well
as in the home in romantic situations we
are taught that our enemies are other
women and our competition is other women
and we need to compete with other women
for for the attention of men whether
that's as potential partners as bosses
as you know if men have power there is
only a certain amount of power allotted
to women women are meant to fight each
other for that power rather than get
together to take more of it
and I think getting over that hurdle is
incredibly hard that psychological
hurdle um I know that it's you know I've
seen it happen within the left myself
and that's not this is not blaming women
for that it's a logical thing to want to
do if you've learned from a very young
age that women are your competition that
you shouldn't compete with men I think
the Internet is helping and the fact
that we can't eat we can speak to one
another directly without those barriers
is helping a great deal and but I think
it will take time for women to realize
that there has to be that solidarity and
and we can now organize without you know
necessarily being restricted within
individual but also when women organize
that organization is true
you know the gossip rumor Network you
know and a lot of the organizing women
do is is dismissed and I think we
shouldn't discount the the work that has
already been done in that way I come
from a women-only College in Cambridge
and I have to say that the main reason
it seems to me that that that apparent
anachronism is I've still got something
going for it is because you get a
critical mass of women who are working
together they're not dispersed and you
know for me in working in a university
that's certainly when I went there and
still is to some extent was
overwhelmingly blue cashed to have a
community which was a women's community
it wasn't so much that it was a refuge
it was a strength should we be thinking
about more female only spaces well I
have to say that it would be insincere
of me to say I come fro Women's College
I think it's a great idea but I don't
believe in women only spaces because
obviously I do but that there is a kind
of paradox here because you know by and
large if you find a place with a lot of
women in it has no power you know if you
want to you want to search out where
power isn't go for where the women are
and in some ways you could do that in
jobs or whatever you know and it's
always my experience in you know in an
organization that has been run by and
for women of women only has been
empowering you know it's my college is
not a place where frail wallflowers go
in order to be protected from men it's a
place where you go to get the strength
of the critical mass of women it's very
important I'm gonna come to the last
question next we will come to the middle
one Miriam this this idea that there's a
kind of on the one hand that problem of
trivializing rape and on the other hand
criminalizing flirting is that the right
dichotomy
is a tiny bit about the previous
question because and I feel that the
explanations that you give are very
convincing I think that there has to be
something there we don't seem to we
don't have power and we don't really
seem to want power sometimes you know
something that really really surprises
me is that we are a majority but if you
really want to think critically about it
we tend to behave as a minority so even
when we could change things and look at
how we organize and you know all these
movements and meet you and all it's
almost like a real world we could be
doing much more with we could be going
for that political power changing things
as women and we don't seem to want to
learn and that is something that always
puzzles me as the way we are not asking
for more insane in terms of actual
change of specific policies that that
all women want and we don't seem to be
getting there I ask for it we're all
crazy and shut down and we women have
been asking for these things for a long
long time but yes we have yes we have
I'm sorry what we do we are called crazy
we shut down with like right now today
in Egypt a woman who just called out
sexual harassment has been arrested for
you know threatening to overthrow the
government because it is a threat I'm
sorry when women turn around the
tribalism wasted person yes and that's
waste like there is this campaign to
stop us when we try and talk we are shut
down on it's not just because we're weak
or we don't want it and it happens to
look to people who apparently have power
you know so no bloke my age saying the
kind of things I do would be talked
about like that eccentric Cambridge
professor with that long hair you know
who doesn't die it would you they all go
their hair and no they're allowed to be
kind of craggy and so and
this place it's a kind of joke um but
another way what is doing is underlining
your right to be taken seriously you
know that that mad woman who teaches the
Romans doesn't brush her hair and you
know we're slightly odd clothes and
always has Sparky trainers on that is a
way of saying we don't need to listen to
her I want to move on we need to get
through the questions Miriam yeah
criticizing rape and criminalizing
flirting I think either line is very
clear the distinction between the two I
think that it is it is certainly true
that we live in a highly sexualized
society but I don't understand some of
these discussions I mean for me the game
of seduction and flirting that is
amongst equals if I don't feel that I'm
in your relationship of equals that is
really not seductions right you know
there may be some fine areas where you
could get into lots of these type of
discussions as to whether it is
acceptable or not but most of its surely
we don't have any doubts as to what it
is whether one camp or the other no
Laurie you know you could talk about
that sore but I want to get through the
questions if we can and ask and answer
this question about women exposing their
bodies wearing revealing clothes whether
that is in a kind of empowerment or
whether that's feeding into what men
wants from women's sexuality yes is the
answer to that like is it like it can be
both of those things it can but honestly
I don't think that the problem with and
I understand I respect the question
partly because it's one that is always
posed to women you know how how have my
clothing choices today made me
responsible for what happens to me in
the world and the answer is that they
don't because whatever you wear like it
will be put down to to that eventually
whether it's you know a burka or a you
know tower bikini there is this you know
I I don't think that what women wear is
the problem I think it's that it's what
men do
that's the problem and you know women
should be allowed to wear clothes
without you know to choose or without it
being you know the first thing there was
a fantastic essay in the 80s and I'm
sorry I forget the name of the rights
but it's about marked men and unmarked
and it's unmarked men a marked women the
idea that as a man you have the option
to be neutral there's a neutral mode you
know you don't have to constantly be
saying something to the women around you
in the same way with your dress whereas
with women are always assumed to be
saying something to men or you're
provoking or basically if they don't
speak and you see that whether the women
cover themselves up they get flak for
that if they take their clothes off they
kept flat for that young and pretty flat
for that like whatever it yeah
everything it's almost like the problem
is that a woman's they're saying
something rather than what she's wearing
okay I'm gonna try and really quickly
get to the last question so gentlemen
they're in the Blue Jackets and then the
lady there I said you ready and there
was someone down here yes I promised hi
there I'll try and make this quick as a
55 year old woman who worked in the city
in the 80s I certainly saw men behaving
badly but picking up on Miriam's point I
have also in my career known women
behaving really badly when I asked for
child rights it was the women partners
who said we never saw our children so we
don't think you should and I see that
more recently and this week I've had an
argument about equal pay and my argument
is if we don't have it not only will our
daughters be undervalued and underpaid
but our sons will never be able to
choose to be carers because their
partners will never be paid properly and
my question is to Mary
and Laurie do you not see any role for
men in this whole argument because I
think if we're talking about changing
the structures of power we are much more
powerful if we bring men with us and I
have seen in my life like Miriam says a
real change
male attitudes thank thank you Mike my
question actually segues onto that
because it was picking up on the point
that Miriam made earlier about the fact
that women also protect the power of men
and can be quite vicious to women and
we've seen that happen with supporters
of Trump and I find that very difficult
to comprehend as a woman why they would
be actually defending him so is it this
ultimately about power and hanging on to
power and the elite hanging on to power
as opposed to a male/female power shift
okay thank you very much let's just
start with the last question I feel like
Miriam and Laurie you've got a bit of a
disagreement over this mirror you say
this is the kind of cultural that the
divide is a cultural one and Laurie you
see this as kind of women internalizing
patriarchy when they attack other women
or reinforce structures there but harm
women yes absolutely I don't sexism
sometimes the man is a woman right and
sometimes the things you have to do in
order to gain power within a system
built by and for men is screw over other
women because and not ask and not lift
other women up and you have to have that
critical mass in order to make those
things possible I do see changes in men
I think I think men are changing where
it was slowly and surely and now you
know panics and hastily right I think
the change has been a little bit too
slow I think that some of the biggest
changes come when men talk to each other
about this stuff and support one another
and and don't you know take that take
sexism as a way of bonding between each
other I think but I'm not really trying
to persuade men that feminism will be
good for them is something that I've
sort of you know I don't want to waste
more of my time doing because I think
it's you know I get shut down and you
know called all kinds of disgusting
horrible things when I do that so I
think it was just gonna have to wait and
see I'm not interested in making my
feminism palatable to men
first off but that's why I there other
people have you know the chance other
people can do that for me you know a
kind of good cop bad cop situation like
there is somebody else will come in and
hold your hand go no no it's ok it's ok
because it is ok but actually you know
in order that what the sad thing is that
in order to make this change happen
faster we have had to threaten them in
fact to threaten men with loss of status
and lots of power in in a serious and
fundamental way we've had to you know
people are now in crisis there is no
this great crisis with people you know
worried about losing their jobs
suddenly in people oh my god are they
going too far it's like well we've tried
to be nice you know we've tried to be
nice for quite a long time and that well
I want to spend all my time convincing
men that feminism is really good for
them I'm the mother of three sons and
I'm absolutely adamant that I don't want
as a mother and my husband doesn't want
as a father of those three sons but they
live in a society where girls feel a
little bit less than them I know for a
fact because I had them that those kids
you know both boys and girls those kids
that by six years old Esther looking a
society in a stereotyped manner they are
not born sexist we happen to them we do
this to them both men and women and
actually what I really would like to do
is to try to get somebody was asking me
about getting boys into the sparing
girls campaign what I want to get is men
into the sparing girls campaign and I
anecdotally have seen in the for a half
years that we have been doing this
campaign at the beginning it was mostly
women whenever we were talking about
this then we started getting the fathers
of daughters coming in and now we get
lots of men there involved I simply want
to have the kind of insider we all want
[Applause]
but just before we go I'm going to ask
each of the panelists to say one thing
that you would like the audience to
consider as an action or as a change
that we should go away from here
mindful of one thing that people can do
that will make a difference so Mary I
think every time you hear somebody use
those words that don't look Jen dirt but
oh you just call them out you know when
somebody says that's an ambitious woman
and scowl slightly you say great you
know I'm pleased and you know you can do
that for a whole lot of the words like
whining screeching you know any number
of those things which go on inside our
head just look I mean we could just face
this and I think you know as I say this
is the academic speaking if you face it
you're half the way to doing something
about it
thank you thank you Laurie I like the
men in the room to consider to sit and
make time to sit with their own
discomfort at what is happening right
now and and not run from it and no no
I'm not I'm being very serious here to
sit with your own discomfort at what's
happening now
own it and and and work out how to try
to make a better world because that is
what we all want and I would like the
women in the room to maybe possibly try
and make like a private vow to not
compete only with other women and to
support one another and be in solidarity
thank you Miriam well I would like
everybody to pay much more attention to
the kind of language that we use because
that really has a big influence on both
boys and girls and and the next
generation I see that is so easy to
change that it only requires us thinking
a little bit more and if I can give you
a practical ask you would make me really
really happy if nobody in this room ever
again says the really horrendous face of
who wears the trousers in this
[Applause]
I'm afraid they are out of time thank
you you've being a brilliant audience
and a round of applause please
[Applause]